In Turkey, the Turkish government approved free refugee movement...
...and recommended a no-fly zone along the Syrian border,...
...after 33 Turkish soldiers were killed by Syrian government forces in northern Syria's Idlib area.
Greek police used tear gas and flash grenades...
...in hopes of stopping hundreds of migrants from crossing the Greece-Turkey border near Kastanies.
Coronavirus transmission rates increased in South Korea, Italy, and Iran...
...while China's rate of infection was steady with hundreds of new cases reported.
Global cases since the beginning of the outbreak eclipsed 83,000 in at least 53 countries.
Global markets continue their drop amid fears the coronavirus outbreak will harm economies,...
...as Asian and European stocks fell again,...
...and American stock indexes declined at least another 2% in early trading.
Finally from Bangladesh,...
...thousands of Muslims protest recent violence in India related to a new citizenship law.
The violence in India left at least 40 dead and hundreds injured.